[Music]  you keep in touch with Kelly Ripa  not really no Regis Philbin tells Larry  King he hasn't really spoken to former  live co-host Kelly Ripa since he left  the show in 2011 she got very offended  when I left she thought I was leaving  because of her I was leaving because I  was getting older and that wasn't right  for me anymore Regis was replaced by  Michael Strahan in 2012 but history  repeated itself in April 2016  when Strahan exited the show for Good  Morning America Kelly was not informed  of the decision before it was made  public I think everybody got this one  wrong impression of it but the great  show great people and I'm very fortunate  to be a part of it we are family  apologies have been made and the best  thing to come out of all of this you  guys is that our parent company has  assured me that live is a priority